What's up everyone? Welcome to the
video. Today we're going to take a look
at how to replace the battery in this
Dodge Charger remote key fob. This key
fob is going to be for the SRT versions
or the Hellcat versions of the Dodge
Charger, and it's going to use
replacement battery CR
2032. I'll put a link in the description
box of this video to where you can find
these replacement batteries if you're in
need.
The other thing I'm going to be using to
change this key fob battery is a
flathead
screwdriver. The first thing I'm going
to do is grab my key fob and remove the
emergency key that's in the bottom of
it. That's done by pressing this release
on the back of the fob that my thumbs
on. And the emergency key will pull out
like that. Just set that to the side.
Now, if we hold our key fob with the
buttons facing down and we take a look
at the bottom of
it, this slot right here is where that
emergency key slid out of. And then just
below that, we see this slot right here
that I'm touching with the end of the
screwdriver. What I'm going to do is
take my screwdriver and put it in that
slot. Then I'm just going to twist the
screwdriver like I'm opening a lock with
a key. And as I do that, you can see it
starts to open the case. I'll come over
here and kind of do the same
thing. Once it's far enough apart, can
just pull it the rest of the way apart
with your hands like that. The back half
of the case, we see our battery right
here. I'll use my screwdriver to get
under the edge of the battery and pop it
out of that little
holder. I'm going to grab my new
replacement battery. And you want to
make sure that you're installing that
with the plus side down, positive side
down. And I'm going to tuck this edge in
first by this metal battery clip. So,
tuck that edge in first like that. And
then snap it down into place. Then we
can snap the two halves back
together. Slide our emergency key back
in. And that's
it. If you could take a second to like
and subscribe, it helps us out and I'd
appreciate it.